Are you familiar with fluoridex?
It's a vegetarian liquid supplement that supports healthy iron levels.
This was suggested to use to help bring up chemoglobin.
So this is fluoridex. We have it in the store.
There's things that I like about it. It's got some really good herbs for blood-building.
What they I don't like about it, it's got cyanocabolomy, but I think it's a fairly low dose.
So I think it's just naturally occurring.
So that's the only thing I don't like about fluoridex.
But yeah, that's it. We've had lots of people use it and it really helped.
So that could help bring up, you know, iron levels, your hemoglobin levels that could be beneficial.